I'm Jay Horton I make movies that make
money this is how
Jay why do you say you are a filmmaker
who makes money
um well I'm making a very like specific
style of movie I'm making low budget
features you know usually under a
hundred thousand dollars and the vast
majority of filmmakers that I talk to
that are making movies at this level a
lot of them aren't making money you know
they're losing from the distributors or
you know they're self-distributing and
not doing anything
um they don't know how to make money I
myself you know I've directed 25 feature
films at this point and you know the
first probably 10 years of my career
like I wasn't making a lot of money on
these movies like I I didn't know how I
didn't know how to navigate it
um I kind of learned how uh later on and
you know I like to make it so that other
filmmakers can maybe get to that point
sooner than I did and so I like to share
some of that knowledge with them you
know it took it it took me a long time
before my you know my movies were
breaking even or making money and so and
and on top of that as I was starting my
YouTube channel you know I was uh you
know there was a couple of growth
experts that I'm following and they have
their little catchphrases I was like I
need some kind of Catchphrase and it
just like that just came out I was
getting ready to do it I was like I'm
Jay Horton I make movies that make money
this is how you know and it just it just
felt like something that would interest
other filmmakers which was you know the
whole goal of the channel in the first
place right you do that in your intro to
the videos yeah it does work when did
you become the filmmaker who makes money
um so I've made money with my films from
the beginning you know I did I did
struggle at the beginning but you know
pretty much I mean my first movie was
distributed in 2003 uh by York
entertainment now it didn't make any
anything but from that and it getting
distributed and out there I started
Landing other filmmaking jobs and that's
where I first started to make money but
like when I say you know I'm jayhaward
I'm a I'm I make movies that make money
I mean I produce movies I direct movies
and I make money off those movies like
I'm not necessarily talking about you
know hey I got I get hired as a editor
or a DP which I have done but you know
I'm specifically talking about making
money off the ex exhibition of the
movies and I would say that started
probably like on a study about
five years ago about five years when
like right around the time that Amazon
started opening up for streaming you
know and that's where I first started
getting the rights back from some of my
older films and finding that you
actually could make a little bit of
money on your own and over the years
I've just gotten better and better at
marketing them at picking the movies and
you know making more money with them
do you think that was a big contributor
is going back and getting those rights
back or new movies going forward once
Amazon Prime opened up yeah it was a
little bit of both I mean it was the the
old movies uh coming back up for license
that made me realize that I could be a
like an entrepreneurial producer you
know I had
um rise of the undead and edges of
Darkness they were released in 2003 and
um around
2014 or 15 I got the rights back for
both of those within like a year and I
honestly at the time I didn't know what
to do with them and uh there was a a
service called create space
um it's owned by Amazon but it was
basically created for self-publishers
like authors but they were doing a thing
where you could give them like your ISO
video file from your movie for DVD and
they would make videos on demand yeah
our DVDs on demand and real soon after
that they started giving you the option
to go on to Amazon Prime and so this was
before Prime video direct but it still
basically a similar process like you'd
upload yourself and get it up so I put
these two movies up on Amazon Prime and
they were making a few bucks a month
like like nothing big and then out of
nowhere uh one of them popped up to like
a thousand a month and then it kind of
hit me I was like oh my gosh like what
if this was a new movie you know because
this is like a 10 year old title at this
point and it's it's doing all right um
so then I started seriously considering
you know producing movies and like hey
here's somewhere where I could put them
even if I didn't do traditional
distribution and so I you know it was
always in the back of my mind and then
after
um I had a little side track with gas
money pictures where I was doing uh
animation Animation studio and that took
me off movies for about two years but
then when I came back
um I was like hey I'm gonna do this like
self-produce you know self-distribute
thing and I started making documentaries
and that's that's where I really got
immersed in like the streaming and
Amazon and then later film Hub and then
back into traditional distribution
was that the point of no return when you
saw that email or whatever with the
thousand dollars yes yes because like
from from that point on I realized that
hey I can self-generate material I can
make these movies on my own without
answering to anyone and I can make a you
know a reasonable amount of money on it
you know if I made a thousand on this
older one could I make five thousand or
ten thousand with a newer one so it was
like hey I didn't I don't I don't need
anybody to do this there's no
gatekeeping it's like it's almost anyone
can put a movie up there so yeah it
really really opened up the the doors to
me being My Own Boss
and with this thousand dollars in one
month were there Rumblings online did
you see more was this the complete
surprise complete surprise so I was
doing absolutely no promotion for it
like you know no no social media it had
no social media presence you know the
like I said the movie was 10 years old I
had pretty much written them off at that
point it was totally just a fluke of the
algorithm you know it was on Amazon and
a certain group of people started
watching it and it just it just took off
you know it got a bunch of reviews after
that and still not a ton like you'll
hear people talking about how critical
user reviews on Amazon are but I've
never really found that to be true I
don't think it hurts but I have plenty
of movies that have made you know 5 000
a month ten thousand a month and they
have you know less than 200 reviews so I
never thought that was a big thing but
yeah it just it really opened from that
point on I was just like hey this is
what I want to do and I've always had
kind of a problem working for people I
just I you know I always wanted to be my
own boss so here here it was I can do it
did you quit a job after that or you
were freelance so I was freelancing
around this time I was freelancing a lot
so I was primarily making my living as
an editor I worked for Fox cutting
promos for a while I would cut other
people's features
um I was hired to direct other people's
features like I directed about 10
feature films for a company called AMG
thumb partners and you know they were
all between 25 and 50 000 after I saw
the self-distribution thing and it took
a few years now you know because I
started making the docs and you know I'd
do one here one there took about a year
before like my money was steady enough
to where I say hey I don't have to do
freelance anymore and I did so I haven't
done a freelance job in probably three
years now
um well I directed one documentary last
year that was a For Hire but it was
based off my you know the stuff I'm
doing now
what's the one thing you wish someone
had had a heart-to-heart talk with you
and said this is what's going to happen
and this is where it's going to be hard
and you learned it on your own and
I I wish that someone had set me down
and been more
um like realistic in your expectations
of what your career is going to be you
know or what it takes to make a living
as a filmmaker so when I was starting
out I had the same you know the same
vision that most filmmakers do like you
know I'm gonna make the slow budget
movie and I'm gonna put it in film
festivals and it's going to get
discovered and some big distributor is
going to pick it up and it's just gonna
it's gonna take off and I'm gonna be
Spike Lee or I'm going to be Quentin
Tarantino or I'm going to be Robert
Rodriguez and and that's what it takes
to be able to make a living doing movies
but but it's it's not so you know
there's a whole like sub level of
working class filmmakers that are making
movies that a lot of people would
consider backyard movies movies shot for
ten thousand dollars or twenty thousand
dollars or thirty thousand dollars and
there are people out there that are
making these movies and can make livings
off of them you know it might not be
rich I'm not on red carpets and you know
I'm not getting Oscars and awards and
all of that but
I'm doing what I love to do and I'm
making a living at it and to be really
honest and a lot of people will say that
I'm uh you know I'm rationalizing it
because I'm not at the higher level but
honestly at this point in my career like
I don't want to be much higher I mean
don't get me wrong if you know if I you
know stumbled on a 500 000 budget as
opposed to a 50 that'd be great I'd love
to do that but as far as like directing
you know like Studio films or Temple
stuff I I have absolutely no desire to
do that any anymore you know I did when
I started but not now but I really wish
somebody had
made it known to me that like you don't
necessarily have to be Quentin Tarantino
to make a living making movies
it's interesting how people's desires
for Success change and maybe you get
tastes of it here and you realize you
know what this is a lot of stress over
here I kind of like this realm where I'm
doing my own thing I'm still accountable
but I don't have to be you know
there's a price to pay I think for
certain levels of a career yeah yeah
totally and one thing that's always uh
been a not a problem but a you know a
source of anxiety for me especially when
I have outside investors like you know I
feel you know you know a moral and you
know and of course a you know legal
responsibility to return the money and
when you're making movies for fifty
thousand dollars or sixty thousand
dollars or twenty thousand dollars most
of the people that are investing in
those movies are not super rich people
you know because like real Like You Know
Rich you know experienced investors
they're not going to invest in a sixty
thousand dollar movie you know and not
because it can't be profitable but
because you know there's a ceiling to
how profitable it can be you know like
yes sky is the limit but you know it's
outliers you know for the most part if
you do a hundred movies at 50 000 the
most one those is going to make in a
year in general terms is you know like
maybe a couple hundred thousand and
that's like at the tippity top so for a
you know a regular investor somebody
that you know invests millions of
dollars or you know they have big
they're that's just not an exciting
investment they're like what I'm going
to put 60 000 and you know two years
later I'm gonna get 150 percent back or
you know maybe 200 it's just not you
know so it's so the people that are
investing in these movies are usually
you know people like myself you know
that you know we're we're making modest
livings we have a good year we might
have 10 or 15 that we can throw towards
something and we do you know and but so
then as a filmmaker when you get that
money you have all this you want to be
able to return it you know one of my
movies I produced back in 2010 and it
was uh I think a thirty five thousand
dollar budget and one of the producers
who I'd worked with for years
um he had it's finally our project to
work together and he had come into some
like family money a family member had
passed or something like that so he had
a little bit of a nest egg and you know
he ended up putting like fifteen
thousand dollars into that movie So
eventually the movie made its money back
but it took a long time and and I felt
that every day until that money was
returned that that's just how I like
like me as a filmmaker I can't take
money and then not return it and feel
okay
you know and I'm still my last narrative
film which I know my tagline is I make
movies and make money but my last
narrative film the campus death day it
was a financial failure it didn't make
its budget back and there was you know
quite a few like two and three thousand
dollar investors in that that you know
they could really use that money and it
never made it and I you know I'll I'll
always feel bad about that
was there a moment Jay when the
Hollywood dream was no more you just
wanted to be a working class filmmaker
or middle class filmmaker
I would say I would say a pro like
maybe around five years ago it started
to occur to me that hey you know maybe
like I'm not going to be directing
million dollar movies you know but but I
still I still kind of hold on to it you
know it was still like that like that's
the goal but somewhere in the last like
two years like moving out to Georgia and
doing the documentaries full-time and
and honestly doing my my YouTube channel
like I just I just realized that you
know I don't I really don't even desire
that anymore I like I don't desire the
red carpet stuff anymore or you know the
adulation of millions or you know
whatever it is it's just it really
became about the work and what I think
what really changed for me for the
better and I recommend this for like all
filmmakers when when you stop making
movies a hundred percent for yourself
and start making them for others is when
things change you know at least it did
for me when I stopped thinking about
mine little precious passion project and
I start thinking about like you know
with the documentaries for example I'm
making a dog rescue documentary and I'm
bringing awareness to you know this
issue and this this the small little dog
rescue that might be struggling like
that's what making that movie was about
you know and then a byproduct of that it
can be financially successful you know
or even you know I'm getting ready to do
a horror movie craving my first
narrative in a few years and but totally
this isn't just like hey this is my
script that I wanted to make you know
the whole time I'm like what is the sub
genre what is the audience expecting
from the sub-genre what can I give them
to make this better you know and and I
think that that leads to you know more
practical success
you had been in La how many years 15 15.
so you came here from Georgia
um now uh the when you came out here
today so originally I was from Indiana I
grew up in Indiana
um and it didn't really seem like uh you
know I was really into movies like I was
a small kid I you know didn't really
play sports I just watched movies so but
there was no like it didn't seem like
that was a real thing that you could do
you know like I was shooting little
videos and stuff but it never crossed my
mind you know before I moved out of
Indiana that movies are something that I
could do and make some money at you know
it's like you had to be in Los Angeles
or New York or and you had to be you
know just famous and discovered and uh I
moved from Indiana to Louisiana I worked
offshore for about a year and a half
saved some money for college and then
decided I was going to go to school and
the University of New Orleans had a
pretty good thumb program and so I went
there studied Communications and film
and this was right around the time that
Panasonic released their dvx uh 100 the
24p mini DV camera yeah and uh it all of
a sudden and in like uh what is it 28
Days Later it come out and I was like oh
it's like it's suddenly feasible to like
shoot a feature film and so I started
thinking more about it has like a
practical career and that right after I
graduated college that summer you know
we pulled together a few thousand
dollars and that's when we shot rise of
the undead which was my first movie
Jay we had this comment come in on our
YouTube channel the other day and I
wanted to read it for you and please
you're welcome to jump in at any time it
goes I made my first and only 16
millimeter feature film in 1997 that
cost me around fifty thousand dollars
that I paid for out of my own pocket
used credit cards and borrowed money
from my parents
however unlike Rodriguez and Smith my
film was a complete and total failure I
wasn't accepted into any film festivals
and wasn't able to get any sort of
distribution this cost me financially
including my future in having a career
as a filmmaker and 25 years later I'm
still dealing with the debt and
financial instability from it 50
000 is a lot of money for most people
let alone 5 million for a film
the reality for myself and I know there
are other aspiring filmmakers who've
gone down the same path like I did that
you only have got one shot and if you
fail both financially and commercially
no one is going to invest in you or
another film because why would they no
one invests in failed filmmakers so like
here's what I'll say to that I and I
don't like I know where he's coming from
but he's also coming from a completely
like a different time 97 shooting on
film yes yeah that probably did cost a
minimum of 50 Grand to get something in
the can but um today it doesn't like it
doesn't cost that much to make it
doesn't have to cost that much to make a
feature film and when when we set
ourselves up that hey I got one shot and
it's this and it's over
like it almost is never going to work
out and in my experience like filmmaking
is a numbers game you know the people
that that you know break out like get
discovered and like take off on their
first films the Rodriguez's and the
tarantinos and Spike Lee and all them
they're lottery winners like like that
that is not the norm most filmmakers
that I know I know very few that did
well in their first movie like almost
almost none I like I can't I can't name
any I didn't actually on the movies that
I produced it took me maybe four films
before I was making like a profit you
know but again I wasn't spending fifty
thousand dollars today you know you just
you just got to you know set a smaller
scale for what you're shooting but you
you can shoot a feature film for twenty
thousand dollars you can shoot a feature
film for ten thousand dollars you know
if you're smart you know if you you pull
in favors you have gear you can you can
do these things we have our we have I
have a phone in my pocket that has a
better camera on it than the cinema
cameras that I did my first like two or
three movies on you know so today I I
just I think that that
I think that one of the biggest problems
with Indie filmmakers they're still
looking at the filmmaking landscape like
it was 97 like it was 2005 and it's not
it's a completely different time you
know there has never been a a point in
history where it's so easy to make
movies it can be so cheap to make movies
and it's easy to get them out there like
on professional platforms you know now
you know and the downside of that is
everybody can make movies and there's a
lot of content we can get into that
later but
I I don't think it's an all or No it
should never be an all or nothing like
I'm all in on this and that's it
um for for me you know I'm the if that's
the path someone chooses to take you
know more power to them but I personally
think it's a numbers thing if you make
five movies
two are gonna fail you know one or two
are gonna break even that fifth one is
going to make enough to cover the other
four you know
excellent and and there's more of this
comment and you know I appreciate this
person for being candid enough to oh
totally and I think you do too it um and
I feel like this is probably
unfortunately a common story and I've
heard from people that have spent
actually double that oh yeah and yeah
and we're in debt and so yeah it's um I
appreciate them for for leaving this um
the fact is movies cost money and
they're a team effort and no one working
on a film should work for free even
though you can now shoot a movie on an
iPhone the fact is not everyone can
afford an iPhone
people like this guy and the commenter
is referring to somewhere interviewing
like to talk about how easy it is
nowadays and use what you have access to
but not everyone has access to the
things people take for granted I
certainly don't have the money to make
another film heck I wouldn't even edit
anything on my 15 year old computer
which I'm still using because I can't
afford anything newer
people with money or access to money
have no idea what it's like when you're
living paycheck to paycheck which is
most filmmakers these days who are not
already established
so I yeah yeah I have a lot of empathy
for that statement and I I do and I also
with everything I just said I you know I
want to you know make known that I I do
realize my my privilege you know I I did
not come for money you know I we come
from minimum wage you know I've paid for
everything myself but I'm a healthy
white male I I've I've had a fairly easy
go of it comparatively
um but that said I I you know when I
made my first movie
um you know this was
2003 uh that we shot at summer 2003 and
I was working at Starbucks
um you know so I was making I don't know
five minimum wage whatever it was and
some tips I worked 35 hours a week and I
was paying for college you know um I was
still able like in that situation to
save a little little bit of money myself
and get a little bit on a credit card
and you know I think that first movie we
made for about
four thousand dollars you know and it
was me and a couple other friends and we
kind of came together on it and put it
together and I know there are people
that are in a position where you know
they can't even like do that you know
with their you know you know people that
start families early
um you know or uh somebody that's
disabled or somebody that has you know
other responsibilities I was a young
single white guy and I didn't you know I
had nothing to do but save up my money
and pay for my college you know so but
all that said it doesn't take that I
think people set up roadblocks for
themselves when it comes to making
movies because you know it's a scary
thing and I think sometimes people it's
easier just to say hey like it's too
hard I'm not gonna do it then to like
buckle down and do it you know and I
like I I buckled down you know and then
and after that movie and that movie
didn't make much money and I was still
broke and I was driving a 91 Ford
Explorer and Katrina happened and I
loaded up my Explorer and with what I
had left and I drove across country to
LA and you know I surfed on a friend's
couch for about six months and I
couldn't get a job I started working at
Starbucks again and the entire I worked
at Starbucks through my first one two
three four my first five movies you know
so like I I would I would work I would
save up a little bit of money I would
shoot and then I'd save up a little bit
more money and I would shoot again you
know I would I would be working uh you
know doing a shoot and we'd finish it
you know three or four in the morning
and then about six in the morning I'd be
at Starbucks you know you want foam on
your latte you know but but like those
are the kind of things if you want to do
it
if you are healthy and you don't have
you know you know four kids
you can make it work if you choose to
make it work I I believe in general
and so you were living in Louisiana at
the time that you were you were paying
for college working at Starbucks there
yes and you managed to do that and then
once Katrina hit you moved here you
drove and would you ever run into people
that you were working with on set while
you were at Starbucks oh yeah yeah it's
so like yeah so I would be I remember I
was on uh my first movie and uh the the
first weekend we shot we had a really
big day it was kind of a Apocalyptic
Zombie movie so we had this sequence set
up in a self-storage facility and we had
like
something like 40 extras I mean it
looked big you know and we were all in
college so you know we had a lot of
college friends come and help so we had
a fairly like impressive looking crew
and there was all these people here it
looked like a big deal you know and then
um the one and one of the one of the
zombies you know I was talking to and
then like the next day
um you know and I say nothing about
working at Starbucks like oh yeah you
know I'm a big time filmmaker and then
you know the very next day they were
right in the drive through and they kind
of like did a double take and they
didn't say nothing but it it was yeah
yeah and I had that happen many times
sure sure and that was in Louisiana or
here that was in Louisiana okay in in
L.A and honestly I can't think of a
situation where it happened because I
you know when I when I moved to LA I was
working at Starbucks in downtown Burbank
and you know I was shooting in you know
Hawthorne or Hollywood and I just I just
didn't I don't remember running to
anybody there but I I may have
been there yeah
Jay you have a video that you did maybe
a year or so ago entitled top five
reasons your indie film is failing yeah
and so we took the liberty of writing
down your excellent tips and we're
hoping to have you read them maybe we
could start with five first okay yeah so
five reasons your indie film is failing
number five you are pushing your movie
in all the wrong places
um so this is what I'm talking about
here is when you have you know a certain
genre of film like you need to
specifically find that audience right
and I find that a lot of people what I
see over and over like when I wrote this
comment I was specifically thinking
about filmmakers that were promoting
their movies and filmmaking groups
because like you'll see this all the
time like you have all these filmmaking
groups and they're like hey go check out
my movie to all the other filmmakers and
the filmmakers aren't necessarily your
target audience if your movie is about
filmmaking
maybe that's right but for the most part
like no that's that don't promote there
you know like that's not filmmakers are
not going to drive that the viewership
you know
um or you know you know people shotgun
out their promotion so you know they're
like let's let's do the exact same post
on Facebook because on Twitter has on
Instagram as on LinkedIn and all of
these social media platforms are very
different in the type of material that
gets traction
you know so like for example you know
like on the documentaries
um I like I do very well promoting on
Facebook and Facebook groups that are
specific to that subject matter
um and on uh Twitter like Twitter with
hashtags that are targeted towards that
target audience but like you know
LinkedIn kinda okay for documentaries
but not so much but like you you should
concentrate on what you're comfortable
with you know like for example I've
spent the most time on Facebook so like
I'm pretty good at writing a post that's
going to engage people on Facebook so
that's where I concentrate a lot of my
promotion you know and you know like
like I'm not as good at Twitter so I
don't concentrate on Twitter as much
I'll put post there but I don't spend an
overt amount of time on it but um and I
don't uh like or I discovered uh
Pinterest a lot of people say like
Pinterest is you know a waste of time
but like I've gotten a lot of really
good video views there you know you know
so I find just you know keep your keep
your promotion you know targeted to the
Right audience you know it's number five
what about a subreddit let's suppose
your documentary is on something that's
medical related or whatever if there was
a subreddit on that so yeah what I've
found with Reddit so I do do a little
promotion on Reddit but I I find in
general uh reddit's not great for direct
promotion like you have to be really Sly
with your promotion on Reddit because
there are like some Facebook groups
there's rules but like Facebook it's
it's really easy to circumvent them like
Reddit you know I've had I've been
banned from mini threads you know for
you know throwing a link in something
like you have to engage with people on a
more personal level there and by doing
that sometimes you can get some interest
in your stuff but just like direct
promotion I I've not had much luck sure
there's too many people that are yeah
ready to come at you yeah that makes
sense okay number four number four
you've picked two broad of you've picked
two broad of a genre so this is like
like you know I'm making a horror movie
right and like that's it that's your
genre that's who you're targeting horror
is a super brunch I'm not saying don't
do a horror movie but I'm saying there
are sub-genres of horror so what is your
sub-genre are you a monster movie or is
it a Siege movie is it a combination of
the two you know what I'm finding
recently uh is that you know
amalgamations and you know combining sub
genres is really cool you know so like
you know the movie I'm getting ready to
do it's a monster movie but it's also a
Siege pitcher you know it has a little
bit of a crime element to it you know
pinching those together but when people
are just like I'm making a drama
where do you promote a drama you know
where where do you promote a general
drama movie now what's that drama about
is it about a small business owner what
type of business is that owner own is
there a community around that kind of
small business like you don't
necessarily have to you know create a
project around your your marketing like
hey I'm gonna create this like double
sub genre no you're making a drama movie
but you don't think of it in general
terms you think of it in specific terms
you know what what what's the race of
the people is this uh is this people of
color is it lgbtq or is it just is it
white folk you know and who are you
marketing to from the beginning so like
I I find narrowing that down really
early on and knowing what your project
is and how to get to those people is how
you Market successfully an indie film
okay let's suppose it's a Mumble core
College film
um early 20s relationship movie
so I would the first first thing I would
do is look at you know there's a if
they're straight or the sexual
orientation I would look at that
um it would be if you're doing a drama
movie these days uh my piece of advice
is find an underserved Market not to
exploit it but to shine light on it to
you know because you know one one sub
genre that's doing really well like on
2B these days is um you know like a
black based uh female focused like
romance with you know maybe a slight
crime tinge to it and like you know 10
years ago those movies were flat you
couldn't you couldn't make hardly
anything on them now they're they're
doing really well because it's an
underserved Market you know so or you
know if your Mumble core thing is it
about is the main character a musician
um let's just say they're a musician so
what type of music is it Target those
types of fans you know or if they're a
baker what kind of Baker is it what kind
of Cook or culinary skill you know find
find things in the movie that are a
strong enough element in the movie that
you can market around it like to Garner
interest because it's really the biggest
mistake I see filmmakers making over and
over with their marketing is they're
it's just it's so General I'm I'm making
I just made this drama movie and here it
is here's my trailer
you have to give people a little bit
more than that you know there has to be
something that they can connect to that
they're gonna have interest in that post
to even engage with it you know great
Point that's very true okay number three
your overall marketing is ineffective so
um
I I honestly don't remember exactly what
I was saying with that one but I think
what I was getting at is uh like you're
you're just being too like generic in
your marketing you're like here like
here's my movie check it out you know
how many filmmakers do you see on social
media here's my movie check it out let
me know what you think
like who who who does that except for
like you're very like good friends or
your mom who who is going to comment on
that you know unless it's to just tear
you down and you know uh chastise you
for making a generic post
um so that in general I think people
look at marketing like they just don't
understand that it's about engaging
people about getting their interest
about intriguing them asking a question
like you'll see over and over on my
posts like I'll promote my YouTube
channel a lot in filmmaking groups but I
always phrase all of my posts has a
question you know if I do a video about
um you know how to how to distribute an
indie film you know my question will be
what are some of your experiences
Distributing your Independent films
here's mine you know and that will
create engagement or if it's uh you know
say you're doing a comedy movie
um about a uh about a startup you know
and you're going to start in some
startup groups and you're like what what
are some what are some of the challenges
that you had starting up like your
startup right and you start getting some
and you don't even post about the movie
and you start getting some comments on
that and then within there you start
dropping in like oh I just I you know I
did this movie about it here it is you
know and that is another way to gain
some engagement in some of those groups
sure and then it turns out you made
Silicon Valley yeah yeah and you make
and you make you make friends this way
it's like networking I mean you know
going back to uh you know like
crowdfunding like that's all about
you know connecting with people you know
it's not everybody says it's about
asking for money it's not about asking
for money it's about connecting with
people and and you are giving them
something for their money whether that's
directly you know Roi worth it is you
know a different story but you know you
are you are providing something that
they want right and with each update you
know you get to root as a group for the
project totally number two is my
favorite
um you didn't think about the audience
before making it you made the film for
you and not them yeah this is my this is
like my my Mantra this has become my
Mantra like over the last probably four
years like I when I started my career I
made movies that I wanted to make and I
would absolutely no thought of
where is this going to play who is the
audience for it who's going to watch it
how much are they going to pay for it
like What's it gonna do I'm just I just
want to make this because this is what I
want to do and I think a lot of
filmmakers start with this mindset and
I'm not I'm not saying that this is like
an evil mindset I'm saying you you have
to balance it with a with a marketing
mind like the the days of you know a
filmmaker you know like uh you know
Richard Linkletter one of them coming in
doing a movie and just blowing up like
I'm not saying it never happens but it's
happening less and less and less you
know so like when we make a movie we do
got to think about
who is who is this for even at the very
beginning when you're writing the script
like
like who is this for what is the genre
what is the sub-genre what are elements
within that genre that people are
looking for and and I'm not talking
about doing a like Cookie Cutter list
and hitting all those points in your
movie Sometimes you subvert those
expectations but you have to be aware of
it you know like what do they want and
if you don't give it to them
are they going to engage with your movie
you know so from from the very very
beginning of any project now like I'm
one of my first thoughts is who is the
audience for this and where do I find
them because if you have no clue then
you either need to go back to the
drawing board or like reverse engineer
you know your marketing early to to
figure it out you know if you're doing a
horror movie you know you're doing a a
horror movie Siege pitcher you know with
uh with a
Hispanic cast you know and you don't
know where to find your audience you
need to start thinking about where to
find your audience as soon as possible
who do you think slacker was for at that
time
I think slacker at that time was for
18. it was for Gen X you know young
um artists you know of I mean like I
wanted to be a filmmaker and I was into
it but there was just there was it I
think it really spoke to that generation
you know and if if I was doing something
like that now like slacker
um I would definitely be targeting like
I would Target some filmmaking groups
for that movie you know because because
it is but I would also be looking
outside of that musicians artists you
know it had a there was uh one of them
was a poet it's been so long since I've
seen it but you know the different
characters were in a lot of different
you know up and coming low income you
know there wasn't a lot of Rich
characters in that so like I would be
looking at you know like and that's
another thing like if you're doing
targeted ads on Facebook for example
like you can kind of you can Target by
you know education level and by income
you know as much as as much info as they
have you know and I think that those
things are are important sure and a lot
of uh conspiracy theory talk too was in
that film which is oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I totally forgot about that
actually yeah the conspiracy theory that
I'd be and there's so many conspiracy
right now like right now if actually
that would be so right now it's just uh
off the cuff like uh uh advice like you
you want to do a little like drama movie
something like that have some character
that's super into conspiracy theories
and tie them directly into some stuff
that's going on and you will you will
have people to push that as long as you
like if you're doing something like that
like don't make fun of them you know
don't exploit them like like even if you
don't believe it or you think it's total
bull like let them have their voice you
know that way like that audience won't
completely turn on you you know I mean
of course you do that within you know
your own moral boundaries don't you know
broadcast something that you don't you
know believe in or you thinks are moral
but if it's not then you know go for it
great and last but not least number one
uh yeah the number one reason that the
indie films don't make money is it's
just not good and and I'm not saying
that all indie films are not good here
but and I'm not saying that it's always
the reason but
we have to be honest with ourselves when
a movie finishes when we like we finish
it it's in the can we got it edited
how did it turn out you know like how
far is this movie gonna go you know like
how much effort do I put into it and I'm
not saying just a man in your movie and
forget it if it doesn't turn out like I
I fully believe you should release
everything you make like release it put
it out you know
um even if you put it out under another
name put it out you know like I I have
never not finished a movie and I I don't
have a lot of
I don't have a lot of sympathy for
people that finish something and don't
put it out you know like like put it out
there's so much effort that went into it
there are people there are people that
want it to be seen like you can get it
out there but I think what happens most
of the time is filmmakers just don't
have
the the distance or the I don't know the
maturity or you know hindsight to say
Hey you know this didn't turn out
exactly how I wanted it you know so they
they think it's their perfect baby but
maybe it's not you know or or maybe it
is good but it's
just because you make a good movie or a
fine enough movie it's not entitled to
make money you know like no no platform
owes you
for it to perform you know the audience
doesn't owe you to watch it you have to
you have to get them in and if you fail
at that
that's that's it's not going to perform
you know and sometimes I think a lot of
movies come into the market and people
haven't paid attention to the other four
things and you know maybe technically
the movie is fine you know like like it
looks good it's in Focus it's got you
know a good production value
performances are okay but they ignored
the audience they made their little
personal film and it has it didn't
deliver anything that an audience wants
or needs and it it doesn't do well
I think number one would be the toughest
to really be honest about with yourself
because you know there's kind of two
camps of people one everything they do
is amazing and two everything they do
they think is crap yeah and I think both
people are gonna have a hard time seeing
their film for what it is it is you're
100 right and I and I sat here and I
just you know went on this whole spiel
about it but I myself struggled with
that for a long time you know I made you
know when I made rise of the undead my
first movie and I you know I'll say it
right here the movie is not good you
know and but it it took me a few years
to to be able to to see it you know
because like I was always rationalizing
it well this is cool or this worked or
you know and then you know it's not
doing well it's not resonating I'm like
why why why you know it's eventually I
ca I think about two years like of it
being out I was you know I was able to
sit down and really say you know what
this this wasn't good and then why
wasn't it good and honestly like it you
know it wasn't the wasn't the image it
wasn't the sound it wasn't the
performances
I didn't spend enough time on the story
and on the script you know we made that
first movie and wrote that script to
have something to shoot you know and two
years later when I'm like why is this
not great I didn't spend enough time on
the script so after that I became really
immersed in like like screenwriting and
writing and you know for a long time if
you would ask me I would say I'm a
writer first and you know then a
director and I think that's when my
stuff started getting a little bit
better
and this was in 2003 yeah that's when we
shot it we shot that in 2003 it came out
in 2005 and uh so it was probably like
2006 or seven where I was like yeah
that's not so great and it took me about
a year to edit that movie you know it
was my very first I mean I basically
learned how to edit doing that movie
Jay you had a great uh question we
talked about in between takes yeah so
I've been thinking about this a while
lately I was like in today's in today's
day and age like can we have
or could we have like a new filmmaker
like like Quentin Tarantino like in the
90s that making that kind of cultural
impact with an independent film like the
way Reservoir Dogs did and I I've been
thinking about this a lot and like
racking my brain trying to even think of
a movie in the last 10 years that came
out from an independent source and had
that kind of cultural impact that
launched a director like that where even
before Pulp Fiction you know like he was
a rock star like can we have that today
and I I don't know because like I was
thinking like the closest to it in the
last like five years might be the safety
Brothers but again not like Tarantino I
mean my mom knew Quentin Tarantino you
know my mom didn't know the safety
Brothers you know what I mean it just I
think today with the proliferation of
streaming and just all of the content
and kind of in our disposable Society
whatever you want to say but I I don't
know that a filmmaker no matter how good
you could make a movie as good as raps
of law dogs there's definitely people
that are as talented as him out there
that you know are making their first
movies but can those movies have the
kind of impact that something like that
had or that slacker had or that Clerk's
had can we have that today and I I I
would say no it would be my my honest
opinion is I I don't think so I'm not
it's not impossible someone may totally
come out and shock me this year but I
don't think so it seems more that the
way things are working now are like like
the safety Brothers where like how many
movies did they make before like we knew
who they were
you know a few you know and they they
built up to you know a heart hard time
or a good time and uh and uh uh uncut
gems they built but they had like what
two or three movies before that I
thought so something something like that
Spirit Awards and I I think they might
have been were they like YouTubers or
something before that I I don't know I'm
getting off but but what I'm saying is
they didn't just come out with a movie
that like boom here we are like like and
who has in the last 10 I I can't think
of anybody I'm sure people will in the
comments but I can't think of anyone
right and maybe because there are more
people trying and also keep in mind we
have these influencers now and nothing
against them but people who just look
good and are creative and do some really
cool Instagram posts or whatever that's
also competing I mean we're just in this
new realm where there's so many people
competing for our attention yeah whereas
at that time the 90s yeah well and and
also not only do we have more people
doing it there's more people doing it
like on a professional level like even
if they're not even if they're just some
YouTuber from Toledo like they have a
nice like 4k camera they got their
lights set up like it looks like like a
pro like TV broadcast from from the 90s
you know whereas in the 90s
you know like to make a movie like look
as good you know sound as good and play
as good as Reservoir Dogs it did it cost
about a million dollars where you could
do that today for you know a couple
hundred thousand you know maybe less
sure and we were getting our information
from Gatekeepers for lack of a better
term and we were going to Blockbuster
and seeing maybe just a few copies of
something versus
um Harry Met Sally on the wall nothing
against Harry Met Sally but yeah 20
copies of that and then you know a few
of these Indie titles that were harder
to find and so those words there was
just a limited place for us to find the
limited amount of you know cameras
weren't you know readily available like
they are now yeah so there might just be
more Tarantino's but maybe they're
buried in the noise yeah I I think so
which which brings up a you know a
bigger point you know about distribution
and how today it's like it's never been
easier to get distribution it's just now
there are so there's so much more
content in the marketplace that the
individual value of those movies has
dropped you know so a movie like you
know if you make a horror movie today at
fifty thousand dollars and you made that
exact same horror movie five years ago
for fifty thousand dollars the five
years ago one is going to be worth you
know whatever 100 two hundred thousand
whereas the one today no matter how it
turns out is you know seventy five a
hundred you know it's just less it's
just worth less you're making less you
know like they talk a lot people talk a
lot about Amazon dropping rates but it's
it's happened
all over the all over the place you know
DVD is shrunk we're not making as much
on DVD deals we're not getting MGS as
much we're making
platforms Distributors you know buyers
they are paying less for movies than
they were you know until you get into
the the studio range
sure and so and too when there were
these special films let's say a
Basketball Diaries
they were so special because there
weren't that many like them yeah now
there's so many amazing films with
Sundance and and all these other
festivals you know there's all these new
filmmakers making so there's so much to
compete but when you had the one
Basketball Diaries then everybody could
focus on that one yeah and there were
all these you know so I don't know if
that's a a relevant point but I think it
is yeah there's just so much I mean they
say the same thing about you know the
home recording uh industry as well do
you think that Talent is no longer
attracted to independent film
I think there are a lot of things
competing for attention with independent
film now and and honestly like
independent film or indie film it's such
a like nebulous like broad term and
filmmaker is such you know a broad term
like like is you know a YouTuber that's
you know that's doing you know Vlog
videos you know with lights and a camera
and sound are they a filmmaker yeah you
know but yeah I think that all of those
things are
like there seems to be a lot of more
easier routes to money now you know like
people see the influencers you know like
single camera Vlogs or just you know on
their phones and they're like why go out
and spend thirty thousand dollars to
make this movie that might only make a
few hundred dollars you know why don't I
just get a camera and set it up and you
know start doing YouTube videos and some
people are attracted to that and I do
think that like some people that might
have you know like tried independent
filmmaking like like narrative films or
documentaries might get sidetracked into
that like like I've invent me I mean
I've made films for 20 years and you
know about five years ago I started
doing YouTube videos you know and for me
it's uh you know it's an extra thing but
if I was starting out all over again I I
might have started there
and you're offering value to people
you're not just quote unquote talking
about yourself you're giving them tips
that could help save them down the line
and interviewing people totally totally
I mean I've always so at least in the
last few years I've been really focused
whether it's my movies or my YouTube
channel and you know it's my I've said
it before it's my Mantra over and over
what value am I adding what am I giving
people that they need or want you know
and I think that that has Led Led me to
doing better
why is it hard to make money as a
filmmaker
so today I think
today I think the easy answer to why
it's hard to make money off movies is
there's just so many of them I mean on
one hand you know I love the
democratization of filmmaking you know
the way you know gear has gotten
affordable you know cameras are more and
more affordable I mean look at the
Blackmagic 6K I mean you can get that
now for what like uh like 2500 for the
body and I mean that kind of Technology
would have cost 90 grand 10 years ago
you know or 60 or something like that it
was crazy and and and that is awesome
and there's all these people like you
know we had the you were reading the
comment earlier and they're talking
about how they made a movie in 97 and
they had to spend fifty thousand dollars
to make that movie I guarantee you you
could make that exact same thing today
not on 16 for fifteen thousand dollars
guarantee it you know I mean well yeah
almost and uh
you know I think that that is super
exciting and cool but on the other hand
because everybody can make movies
everybody's making movies and they're so
it's so hard to get
attention it's so hard to get eyeballs
on your individual project because
there's just so much more of it and then
you know and again because there's so
much more of it so many more places to
put it the value of those individual
projects is less now and I think that is
the main reason that it's harder today
to make money on Films than it was 10
years ago what do most independent
filmmakers get wrong about making money
from their Independent films
um I sound like a broken record with it
but I think the number one thing
filmmakers get wrong is they don't think
about the business I you know and I'm
not saying it has to be like all
business and business first and then
creative no you like it your movie has
to be good the creativity has to work
that's a given so like I got some
pushback on my channel early on because
I was talking all about distribution and
marketing they're like well well what's
the movie is just not any good you know
the movie has to be good I'm like well
yeah that's that's a given your movie
has to be good that's like duh but what
people don't put any focus on or don't
want to they don't want to think about
the business you know and again because
so many more people are doing it you
have to be better and better at getting
eyeballs on that project like you have
to be able to Market yourself and not
and not just your movie you have to be
able to Market yourself like there's a
there's a misconception I think with a
lot of filmmakers where they think I'm
going to do this great movie and it's
just going to speak for itself and I'm
not saying that that never happens still
I'm sure it does but for the most part
we have to get out there and become the
face of it or somebody does like we have
to sell it you know and we have to sell
ourselves you know like now it's not
enough to be an independent filmmaker
make a couple of movies and just you
know Coast off of that let let the
movies bring in all your income you have
to get out there and you have to you
have to become oh man I hate even saying
this but you have to become our brand
you know like that's where it is and and
if if that all sounds like disgusting to
you and icky yuck
second you need the second thing being a
being a filmmaker a professional
filmmaker today and when I say
professional filmmaker again I'm talking
about filmmakers that are making money
off the exhibition of their films I'm
not talking about DPS they're getting
hired to do stuff I'm not talking about
Gaffers that are hired to do stuff I'm
not talking about for pay directors I'm
talking about people that are you're
going to go out there and you're gonna
put the movie together as an
entrepreneur and make money off of it
what if someone says though because
we've been talking about you know Kevin
Smith Spike Lee uh Richard linklater
um and Robert Rodriguez Quentin
Tarantino what if those are some
interesting people they're just
interesting to listen to yeah yeah you
know you just put them at a Podium I I
heard Kevin Smith speak at a conference
and and he's just fascinating so but not
everybody's like that yeah
that's true
um so I think it's a matter of like
leaning in to your strengths you know
like like like me for example I like I
am not as charismatic as say like Kevin
Smith or Quentin Tarantino and like I'm
not as knowledgeable about film as
Quentin Tarantino you know and honestly
like like I sound like I'm pretty good
on camera now but I've been I've been
practicing this on my YouTube channel
now for three years you know so like I
I'm decent now but I had to work at it I
mean at the very beginning I was very uh
uh didn't know where to look didn't know
what to do with my hands am I gonna talk
am I talking with my hands too much like
I I was on and the whole time you know
that imposter syndrome kicks in and
you're like nobody cares what I have to
say like I'm talking about making fifty
thousand dollar movies and making a
modest living on it who cares about that
we all want to be rock stars we don't
want to make million dollars nobody's
going to listen to this and but I just I
just kept at it and building it and then
over time you know it built up a little
bit and people started responding to it
and it's it's helped feed all of my
other work and all of the effort that I
put into getting better on camera and
stuff like that you know I just did a
crowdfunder and I did a pitch video and
you know no no ego I think I did a
really good pitch video and ninety
percent of that is me being able to
present on camera better because I've
I've practiced it for three years you
know and just as a quick side note the
amount raised was oh we raised uh fifty
seven thousand dollars now
congratulations thank you it's great
yeah Indiegogo yes excellent yeah
excellent what was the biggest mistake
you made in attempting to make money
from your films or was that the biggest
mistake that that was your end goal and
that shouldn't have been and therefore
that was the mistake
my biggest mistake making I keep
repeating the questions my biggest
mistake uh
um in not making money on early films
was looking at it waiting for someone
else to to do it for me whether and this
isn't an anti-distributor tirade or
anything because I I Distributors at
their place I like them I still use
Distributors but there's this thing with
like new filmmakers where we just want
to make our movie and give it over to
something and then that thing is going
to bring our money in and we don't have
to worry about it it's somebody else's
problem it's somebody else's job to
Market it it's somebody else's job to
distribute it it's somebody else's job
to think about the audience you know and
and it's in if you're making a movie at
a certain level it can be but if you are
making fifty thousand dollar movies or
twenty thousand dollar movies you don't
have what money in the budget to hire
those people so you have to do it when
eventually I came to the realization
that like
I just have to do all these things I
have to learn it and I have to do it and
once I came to that realization and
started working towards it it's like
it's like the world stopped fighting me
you know if like before it was just like
everything was fighting me I would you
know I was like I I need to go with this
distributor because like they do
marketing and they're going to do this
this and that and it didn't work out and
then you know I did another one and it
didn't work out and I'm like what am I
doing wrong I'm I'm counting too much on
others to make my dreams come true you
know at a certain point and I'm not
saying to not collaborate or not to ask
for help or not to seek out you know
other people to help facilitate your
success but at the end of the day it's
like you have we have to do it for
ourselves
do you think that and I'm going to sound
a little classist here but it comes
under the uh DIY sort of punk ethos or
or working class filmmaker whereas
someone else and again people are going
to come at me for this but I don't want
to get my hand started I don't do that
someone else can do that for me yes I I
think I think that's absolutely an
element of it and and I don't think it's
always a like you know like the like a
classist like oh I just like I'm too
good for that I think a lot of people
are really scared of it like I like when
it comes to marketing or like brand
building I think most filmmakers are
scared of it like and and then they'll
they'll they'll twist That Into You know
like I'm too good for it or you know or
into anger or I shouldn't have to do
that you know and they'll get mad but
you know I I I think a lot of like you
know bad behavior like in filmmaking
comes from anxiety and being scared and
it's scary it's a scary thing you know I
I suffer from pretty extreme social
anxieties and I like every single movie
I'm I'm an anxious wreck you know but I
I get I get through it but then on
camera you ease through it and and
you're interesting to listen to and you
have great tips yeah you know it's it's
so it's so weird like I I was a uh so I
I've always been a super anxious person
but like I've also always had like a
performance bug you know like I you know
really early on I wanted to be an actor
or a singer I I was in a rock band right
out of high school like I could I could
get up right now and you know go to a
carry our karaoke bar and like like tear
up some karaoke right and wouldn't be
nervous at all but you know say like I
had to go do like a like a like a
one-on-one
um like like Ted talk or something like
that where I'm that and I and I couldn't
like write it out or have it you know
like on teleprompter or something that
would freak me out you know or like I
have trouble as a producer it's a really
it's a problem for me as a producer I
have trouble like like calling people
like you know like like reaching out
like I'm looking for a location so this
person owns a location I have trouble
making that call you know I I do it but
I have but I have problems with it but I
can go on camera and blah blah blah blah
blah blah but then I get nervous doing
live streams you know like I get really
nervous doing live streams
what do you love about Amazon Prime I
love that I love the Amazon like
you know sometimes that people think I
suffer from Stockholm syndrome defending
Amazon but they opened up independent
film distribution in a way that it has
never in history been done like Amazon
Prime made it possible for an
independent filmmaker in Indiana making
a six thousand dollar like backyard
horror movie to distribute their film
and have it on the new release wall like
right next to Fast and Furious you know
that is cool and and initially it was
paying pretty good I mean I I don't
remember what the what the first rates
were but I think it was like 15 or 20
cents an hour which some people say that
like that sounds low but you can make a
lot of money at 20 cents an hour on a
streaming platform on a platform like
Amazon where there's like whatever 90
million users watching you know I I I
think it was incredible I think they
made mistakes
um you know and I I think the biggest
mistake Amazon made was there was no
curation now you know I keep talking
about how great it is that there was no
gatekeeping or you know no curation but
I think there needed to be a base level
of curation like they were taking
anything uh things that weren't even
movies like you know they they were
taking shorts there were people putting
up like YouTube style videos like and I
I think that all of that inappropriate
content is what it really like started
the the downfall of it some people will
say that it was always planned that they
were always going to get rid of Indy and
maybe they were but I think it at least
would have held on longer had they not
been putting out YouTube videos and you
know there's a filmmaker that I know
that was putting his stuff right from
YouTube onto there and you know calling
them documentaries but they were not
they're like Vlogs like I do you know on
there you and I would never put that on
Amazon but I think that's what led to it
but
I mean like I owe a lot to Amazon it it
opened up my eyes to what like
independent filmmaking could be
financially and and now it's kind of
gone but other things have popped in you
know like to be what are three tips a
filmmaker new to Amazon Prime should
know about getting their movie up there
well so three things people should know
about Amazon the fir first thing is that
it's not what it was so now if you are a
filmmaker and you want to upload
directly to Amazon you cannot do it for
subscription base the svod the only
thing that you can do is tvod and it I
think now you can do documentaries again
but for a while they weren't taking docs
at all but I think for tvod now you can
still submit you know narratives or
documentaries and you'll make you know I
think they pay like 50 of the rental or
the purchase price to you so it sounds
pretty good and if you have if you have
a title that you know has some legs you
know that that is good that might have
some Stars you might do good with tvod
but the first thing to know though is
that you can't
you know you can't just upload and be
free with prime anymore you have to go
through a distributor or an aggregator
and and they're pickier than they were
so like like you know some chintzy
things are still getting up but not not
like it was before so it's harder
um then now so let's say you're going
through a distributed aggregate or you
get and you get up there so what are
some things that you need to know in
order to do well there I think
filmmakers need to
like wrap their heads around
I'm trying to so what I where I learned
this from was doing YouTube so when I
started growing my YouTube channel I
started watching all these YouTube
growth experts right people with you
know three four hundred thousand
subscribers and they're talking about
this is how we grew our business and
they start talking about looking at
analytics they start say thinking about
hooking the audience early and keeping
them engaged and giving the audience
what they need and I started thinking
about my features like that you know so
like
you know like now I would be much more
hesitant to do like you know a movie
that had an opening like Slow Burn 20
minutes like I would I I would be
hesitant to throw that up for something
that's going to perform on a streaming
platform because in today's day and age
you know they used to say like with
screenplays you have 10 pages like you
know to hook the person
not anymore you got like you got like 60
seconds like if something is not
happening that is going to engage the
audience early on they're out of there
so like you like you front you gotta
front load some good stuff you know so I
think about that
um and then I've talked about
um
you know uh like engaging in in the
algorithm so you know when you're typing
out your description and even if you're
going through a distributor nine times
out of ten filmmakers are still writing
their own synopsises and stuff like that
so start thinking about that that is
your first like thing to start thinking
about like SEO you know search engine
optimization so like using keywords and
and then you want it and you need to be
able to blend those keywords into your
you know sentence and paragraph so it
sounds organic and not clunky but you
know you're thinking like I'm doing a uh
I'm doing a horror movie with you know
zombies and vampires right zombies
versus vampires so like you want zombies
in your description and in a couple
different ways you want like zombies
Undead
um you know try to think try to think of
like three different terms for like
zombies and then try to think of maybe
three terms for vampires and then try to
find a way within that paragraph to work
as many of those in as you can you know
and because these like Amazon there when
people search like these keywords come
up and they're they're matching you know
audiences with their keywords so it's
you know it's important so think about
that
um and then
um you know think about where you're
gonna what what kind of movies like do
better on Amazon
and Amazon
isn't a super like like Indie Indie
friendly thing now so like if you are
doing an indie film The indie films are
going to do better on Amazon are going
to be stuff that have a little more of a
like like a mainstream feel like a
little less nichy you know or
you know they have and no no extreme
like violence or sex or drugs like you
really gotta it's all it's really weird
because I remember when I started I used
to always say hey if you're going to
make a ten thousand dollar movie you
might as well just go balls to the wall
and throw it all out there and not worry
about nothing this is the time to be
punk rock
not necessarily if you want to if you
want to make any money off of them
because you know and then now that uh
avods are starting to take off a lot
more than the subscription-based
platforms you know stuff like 2B or IMDb
TV or even YouTube now those uh you know
you're getting paid from the advertisers
and the advertisers have to be matched
with your stuff so the advertisers that
pay the best are usually more for a
quadranty you know so like you know on
YouTube for example you know if you have
a documentary about cannabis you're not
going to make anything because you're
going to they're gonna 18 like restrict
you and the you're gonna have a really
low CPM and you won't make much money so
you need to you need to think about
those things too
do you have a narrative about a dog that
saves Christmas
perfect perfect for Amazon Christmas dog
movie oh man you know a friend of mine's
actually doing a Christmas uh Pig movie
right now okay it's doing very well on
YouTube actually yeah very cool what
about um cover art
uh most important thing uh for the
marketing of the film is the cover art a
lot a lot of people will say trailer
nope cover art because like in this and
the streaming like that is the thing
that gets people to stop it's the art it
is if you're gonna spend money on
something like for marketing
spend it on your cover art like if
you're a decent graphic artist but you
can come up with you know a thousand or
you know five thousand or whatever pay
the money and get a pro once sheet done
if you can you know I I so I'm I'm a
decent graphic artist and for my first
probably year like doing docs I was just
doing all my own I was like this is good
enough this is good enough this is good
enough and then you know one day I was
like you know what I'm gonna try I'm
gonna I'm gonna hire somebody out so you
know I hired a graphic designer I think
I paid 600 bucks for it and it did way
better than my average stuff so then
from then on everyone I put the money
into it
how does the back end of distribution
work let's say we have a movie that
makes a hundred thousand how does that a
hundred thousand get divided up
I mean it really depends on the movie
um on on most NDS like the way I
structure most of my films so let's say
I'm bringing in investors
um I typically go investors first and
first out so if an investor puts in
twenty five thousand dollars the first
twenty five thousand dollars the movie
makes goes to the investor
um another way you could do that is you
could say
the first uh the first monies that come
in up to that 25 000 you split 50 50
with the investor until the 25 is paid
off and then once it's paid off maybe
their backend goes to like 20 or
something like that
um but you know as far as you know where
it comes in if you're not going through
a distributor like say you're doing film
Hub or self distribution it pretty much
goes directly from the platform to film
Hub to you you know and like it's and
it's all pretty like automatic and
automated or if you're doing it yourself
like through Amazon it's just Amazon and
you you know but in today like today
three years ago I would have said do
Amazon on your own and then do film Hub
you know for everything else today I
would say just let filmhub do it all
because you know the more that they have
data for the more data points the more
platforms you're going to be eligible
for the more they have to work with to
sell your film it's just I I just let
them do it but wouldn't film nothing
against film Hub but wouldn't they be
getting more of a cut because it's more
of a middle person
or know that the platform film Hub is
its own
search and play no no no they are
getting they're getting so the like the
way film Hub Works um they weren't just
kind of like an aggregator so it's like
they they placed the movie with Amazon
and then Amazon does whatever their
split is with them which might be 50 50
and then whatever film Hub gets you get
80 of what filmhub does so yeah you are
losing another piece there but like
you're just in today's in today's age I
don't think there's a lot of value in
just going for one platform you know so
like maybe two years ago Amazon was the
highest playing platform but there's
like these 20 other ones and once you
add start adding those up there they
become comparable you know and you know
if you were not giving film Hub Amazon
because like Amazon's like it was like
the first line of either defense you
know it's like the first platform it's
the first thing they start getting
numbers on and the more your movies
doing the more attractive it's going to
be to other platforms whereas if you
they didn't have those Amazon numbers
they just had all the little ones your
movies not looking as
attractive to other platforms so they
might not take it you know so and then
the other thing that's happened is now
Amazon started their own avod service
which is IMDb TV which is apparently and
it's still fairly new but you know we're
on the street anyways it's going to be
paying more than what Amazon was because
like avod's doing better these days but
you can't go to IMDb TV on your own and
if you just upload to Amazon on your own
your unless your movie Just does like
exceptionally well it'll never be
eligible for indb TV but like on through
film Hub or through a distributor they
can get there you know but you can't
necessarily do it on your own and having
those Amazon numbers helps them to make
help gives you a better chance to do
that where else does film Hub upload
your content
I mean they have film Hub has probably
uh like a hundred platforms they're
working with like on their website they
have a list and and it's all the The
Usual Suspects you know the the 2B
Amazon uh hoopla stream go media
um you know they have connections with
say Apple TV like they just signed a
deal with Apple TV I just had my first
movie selected for there actually not
sure what the returns are yet but we'll
see and it's just and it grows like you
remember everybody's talking about how
like how great to be is right now for
independent film 2B has been around for
you know I don't know 10 over 10 years
and you know five years ago
it wasn't that big a deal you know like
you weren't making that much and now
that little platform that was there on
film Hub that I was making nothing off
of is now where I make 80 of my Revenue
you know so who knows what the next
one's gonna be you know like because
because eventually I think these things
you know they bubble out they burst
something else comes up so what was
going to be the next one it might be
Plex like right now on through film Hub
you know you're making pennies on Plex
but maybe five years from now that'll be
something substantial
and is it guaranteed that your film if
you do have film Hub acquire it is on
all these platforms or maybe some of
them can't be placed there no it's it's
not the the only thing about film Hub is
none of it is guaranteed like you're not
guaranteed to be on any platforms you
know it's it's totally up to the
platform whether they'll take you or not
but the cool thing about film Hub and
the reason I I keep using them is you
know it's completely non-exclusive so if
film Hub can't get my movie to 2B but I
can get it through someone else I can do
that you know I have that freedom
do you have the rights back to all your
films
um I have the rights to most of them at
this point
um I I have been working with uh Indie
rights uh distributor over the past
couple years so I think they have like
five or six of my titles
um aside from those I think I own
everything at this oh and uh death days
with uh ITN how much would your movie
have to make in order for you to get a
hundred thousand back
as a filmmaker on a platform oh um
wow that's a good question
um
I'm sure it varies from yeah yeah it
would vary but let's just say most of
them do most of them are like 50 50 or
60 40 with the distributor aggregator
and then maybe another 20 on top of that
so you'd be looking like at a hundred
and fifty
we need to make like like 100 between
150 and 175 to make a hundred something
like that
and that would be normally what span of
time probably over several years I mean
it again it really depends so for for me
um you know I have about I have about 60
titles in the market that I see numbers
from on a regular basis and you know my
titles make between you know as little
as a few bucks a month you know all the
way up to five or six thousand a month
you know which so you know if I have one
that's making 5 000 a month you know you
know take a a year to do that
um but you know I I've seen numbers from
other titles you know a comparable
budget levels to mine and even under
that are making as much as you know
twenty thousand a month or you know
there's one uh just just this last month
that I saw that did a hundred thousand
dollars in a month you know now these
are outliers you know I think my like
General five to like few dollars that's
where that's where most are living
between five dollars and like 1000
and are there certain platforms where if
it's not family friendly don't even
bother like don't waste your time don't
waste their time
um yes um all the to be honest I I don't
know too many off the top of my head I
like I'm starting to experiment a lot
with putting titles up on YouTube
because you know my my channel is
monetized and now a bunch of these uh
networks have come out multi
multi-channel networks I think they call
them mcns and a lot of Distributors are
striping striking deals with these
different companies so for example uh
Indy rates put out uh my uh UFO
documentary I want to believe through a
multi-channel network and you know on
their YouTube channel it was making a
couple hundred dollars a month you know
not not much on the off of YouTube and
when they put it on that multi-channel
thing it did like uh like 2 000 in a
month just there you know but but on
YouTube the extreme stuff is not going
to be matched with good advertisers so
it needs to be family friendly but you
know like something like like 2B that's
also Advertising based but they're a lot
friendlier to like you know horror and
you know more graphic content so like
you know like I'm seeing I'm seeing
really big numbers from 2B on some
pretty graphic stuff and it's a DOD and
I would assume IMDb TV is the same way
and UFOs not considered family friendly
no no the UFO one it was is was family
friendly okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it just it billions were fully closed
yeah yeah yeah they were fully clothed
there was no sex with them but um but
the difference though was you know their
their Channel it just the multi-network
channel has millions of subscribers and
they're specifically targeted for like
Supernatural stuff so like the only
stuff on that channel you know they have
some documentary and some narrative and
it's all like UFO paranormal based so
they've they've really got their
audience
um speaking of India rights there's a
filmmaker that works with them named uh
owl prophet and he does like the true
crime like documentaries very low budget
stuff and I mean he's got a huge YouTube
channel he makes a ton of money off that
his movies then like double dip uh
through Indie rights through you know to
be in Amazon he's making more money
there and he's like he's really like
that that's the guy where I started
looking at the documentary thing as like
a viable option and he's like he's he's
really got it on lock
well so true crime but I would imagine
summer graphic yeah it's like and it's a
kind of a specific like True Crime too
like his tend to deal more with like
like drugs like you know like you know
cocaine or heroin they taught like he
had a he had an Al Capone documentary
like stuff like that
what's the fastest you've ever made a
feature film
so the fastest I've ever shot a feature
film is in a day
um I made of I've made one two three I
did three one day features and one two
day feature so I was working for a
company I was directing movies for them
and I did about 10 10 or 11 projects for
this company and their budgets were
typically between like 65 000 down to as
low as 30 25 or 30. and we would
typically shoot these in like five to
eight days so
um they had a filmmaker friend that was
doing these like filmed plays in Atlanta
like basically setting up three cameras
and just shooting the plays and then
they would kind of release it as a
feature and I was talking to him one day
um and we were talking about that thing
and I'm looking at it and I'm you know
I'm an editor and I was sitting here
thinking about it and I was like God if
we had the sets real sets like like I
could I could do this and make it like a
real movie like not like a filmed play
like do it with coverage I could I could
make this work and so uh he was like and
he started thinking about it and so like
their big thing was they would get like
you know a uh you know kind of a fallen
like like B actor they would put him in
the movie just like those like Bruce
Willis things where he's in the movie
for like five minutes and it's like
starring Bruce Willis so like they were
doing that kind of thing and but they
were like gosh though if we did this in
like one day we can just meet this
person's day rate and they can be in the
entire movie they could really
legitimately start in it and we can get
a few of them so they're like yeah we're
gonna cast like this person this person
this person we're gonna do it in a day
so I would uh basically we would run
these things we would do them on sound
stages so like sets and there would need
to be like all the company moves would
need to be within that Sound Stage so
you know like like Cafe they have a cafe
they have a bar they have an apartment
okay it's got to be in a cafe a bar and
apartment so then you know we would set
up the three cameras and you know I
would do you know kind of a basic wide
shot
um I do a
you know like a maybe uh like a two over
here and maybe uh maybe three people
over on here one piece of cover three
pieces of coverage run the run the scene
so and then we we do the scene once or
twice you know until we get all the way
through it you know and then move the
cameras and you know like start punching
in on people and do this me on an on
average uh two times per scene so you'd
have six pieces of coverage for every
scene you know sometimes more depending
on how shorter long the scene was and
you know like on that second one you
know I'd have good operators and you
know like they would be fishing
close-ups and then you know in between
takes they'd be popping inserts and and
we did it we shot at like 85 pages in a
day and just just knocked them out and
we did there was one month with those
with that company where I shot four
movies like in a month we did a five day
um two one days and a two day and just
bam and then and then you know I'd have
three or four weeks to edit them
so does the talent know that they're
getting their day rate but then they're
like in every scene yeah oh yeah okay
yeah because you know on on indie films
it's almost all about all the
negotiations with Talent are usually
based upon time on set you know so like
now I was not privy to those
negotiations so maybe there were some
bumps because they were all the way
through it I like I don't know I didn't
I wasn't a producer but I I would assume
though that they were pretty much
getting their day rates
how is that on the actor especially for
these you know shooting a feature in one
one day so it can be very hard on the
actors and and the director and the crew
um it takes a very you know and this
isn't just one day features either when
you're making a extremely like low
budget short shoot movie whether it's
one day or five days or ten days there's
specific types of actors that can deal
with that kind of situation and there
are some that can't it's not necessarily
a matter of Talent OR ability some just
can't work under those circumstances so
one of the it wasn't one of the one days
but it was like it was a five day
feature we were working on and one of
the actors uh was a name actor and they
could not handle the the pace and you
know nothing like there it was a very
good talented experienced actor but you
know they kind of broke down halfway
through the first day and like took me
aside and like just tears streaming like
I like I I can't I can't do this I can't
get to where you need to me to go like
they couldn't they just couldn't do it
so they ended up having to you know find
someone else to do that part
um and that's the only time that ever
happened to me but but it's a very
specific like you know type of actor can
do that so like when I'm when I'm
casting uh a movie one of the as a low
budget you know quick schedule movie
like I look at their experience have
they shot other movies like this do they
understand what this set is going to be
like do they understand that this is
going to be like Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam you
know that you're only gonna get you know
even on the five day features you know
you're gonna get an average of
three takes two and a half maybe you
know it's it's and some actors can't get
there in three takes you know like they
they need more you know they're they
need a longer rehearsal period or you
know like we even on the one days we do
camera rehearsals but they're they're
they're quick you know so it's not like
like long blocking rehearse or a long
camera rehearsal and if you're in the
same space sometimes the camera
rehearsals start getting 86 and you're
just you're just rolling through it and
they they they they have to do it so
it's it's there's some people that
thrive on that like I used to describe
shooting features really fast as kind of
like shot clock pool you know it's like
you don't really have time to like line
up and you know agonize over the shot
you just take it you just take take it
take it take it you know and I
personally like I I thrive off of that
like I like that I like the challenge I
I wouldn't
I wouldn't shoot a one-day feature again
like like ever you know I did them you
know I'm happy I did it but I I wouldn't
recommend it they're not the best movies
that I ever made but they're better than
you would think you know
um but anyway I like the I do like the
challenge of it
in a situation like that is there a
place for the main actors to go to
collect themselves or they're all in one
space wardrobes here everybody's just
out in the open together yeah no no no
it's like like they would typically
these would typically be like regular
sound stages so you know there'd be
green rooms and holding and you know
that I have been on sets where you know
you know like you're on a practical set
and there basically is no holding I mean
I did I did a talking dog movie once and
you know we had some name talent and you
know they're like okay we have to have
this room set aside for them you know
because you know in their writer or
whatever but I forget what happened but
they like didn't have the room and the
person was like totally cool but here
was this like like person that you'd
seen in all of these movies like growing
up and they're they're sitting there
like on the floor in a corner between
dates but they're but they're totally
down and you know I think that even like
name actors when they're working on
something like that they like they know
what they're getting into you know or
they should and honestly I think like
with that as long as you are
communicative and you don't like promise
something that it's not and you're
really upfront about hey this is what
this is and like this is how it's going
to work and we're gonna do our best to
make you comfortable but you know this
is the situation
most of them will roll with it you know
and and if you get a little you know
pushback or you know like hesitation
go to somebody else you know sure and
sometimes they might be fine but as you
know an extra or or another smaller
actor may want to go and talk to them
yeah and during downtime and that's kind
of their time to replenish and then they
don't really okay they're always on you
know so I think that could be a problem
and I found you like even in those cases
like those practical locations we still
try to find like even if it's not their
official like you know room we try to
find Space to where they can be or it
doesn't have to be name actors even like
you know the movie I'm getting ready to
do now we have a lead actor and he's
very good and like he needs like like he
needs about he said he needs like two
minutes you know uh before each like new
setup that like he needs to be alone and
not messed with you know and that that's
that's totally a valid process sure you
know it's just sometimes on Independent
like really really indie films you you
have to make some concessions you know
and sometimes like you just you can't
cast that actor you know it not like in
in this case I'm able to make it work
but you know on another movie maybe
maybe I wouldn't and I would look for
someone that that's why whenever I'm
casting to like in auditions I always
ask people like how do you like to be
directed like how do you like to work
and you can start getting an idea like
hey are we gonna Jive is this person
going to be able to handle the rigors of
you know a twenty thousand dollar you
know five day shoot
why do you make movies for less than
fifty thousand
I think most people that make movies for
less than fifty thousand are making it
just like me because that's that's
that's
what we have to work with you know or
that's what we can raise I mean I would
uh I would feel much more comfortable
like like as far as like production goes
working around 200 000 or 300 000 you
know making a fifty thousand dollar
movie is tough no matter how you cut it
no matter what the scale of it is trying
to pay people Fair rates and like it's
next to Impossible so I make fifty
thousand dollar movies for one because
that's
like that's the ceiling of what well
close to the ceiling of what I can raise
myself or pay for myself you know
anything beyond that it starts getting a
little like hairier you know so and then
as far as returns like to be perfectly
honest I like I wouldn't feel 100
comfortable right now taking a hundred
thousand dollars on a movie I wouldn't
be positive I could return that back
fifty thousand for the right movie I I'm
80 90 sure I can return that back or at
least most of it 100 I don't know
when you say the right movie are we
talking narrative are we talking
documentary I it could be narrative or
documentary when I say right movie I
mean like you know the uh genre that's
doing well in the market
um a you know a you know a scale that
you know I think would work at that
budget level you know for example I'm
getting ready to do a horror movie and
it's called craving uh budgets right
around you know 50 60 000 and you know
it's a it's a Siege pitcher takes place
mostly in one location
um it has some incredible creature
effects and right now as far as
independent films go independent horror
movies creature stuff is doing really
well and if your creature is good like
it can do really well like let's let's
just say for example the movie kind of
turned out mediocre but those monster
things are all really good like that
movie can still like you know make that
budget back and then some based off the
monster it's almost like what name
Talent was to you know horror movies
five years ago you know the monster
becomes the name
you know so if you think that a movie is
over 50 000 then you realize I may have
to take a producer's money and I don't
want to add that stress
I don't want to have to
I mean that's a lot of stress on
someone's shoulders to be accountable
for that yeah so so the 50 000 is a safe
place for you because you know you can
do that on your own yes yeah and and and
also just to start thinking about it on
a on a back end way and you'll hear a
lot of filmmakers say hey if you don't
get paid up front you're not going to
get paid and you know maybe if you're a
DPA or director of higher that's true
but has an entrepreneurial producer
you're making ever your back end is
everything you know so if I make if I
have a fifty thousand dollar movie and
say a producer comes to me tomorrow and
they want to put in fifty thousand so
now it's a hundred thousand dollar movie
how much back-end do I have to give to
that producer you know they're putting
in fifty percent of the budget so let's
just say for the sake of argument you're
gonna have to give them you know half of
the back end you know fifty percent and
how much more is that movie actually
gonna make in the Market at a hundred
thousand as opposed to 50. is it enough
that that 50 is worth it because I make
my living off of my back end so if I'm
losing half of my back end is the movie
going to make more than 50 percent
higher that you gotta have you got to
think about stuff like that you know and
in this particular case
like unless you know I guess I guess
maybe at 50 maybe maybe if I put in like
a like a a bigger name actor like if I
put 25 of it and hired like Tony Todd or
something like that
maybe that would help it but I I
honestly don't know
um you know I have a friend who just did
uh did a horror movie A couple of years
ago and had some two like pretty good
like you know like upper level like B
actors the movie should have done
gangbusters and it did you know so
if 50 is just I think 50 is a safer bet
right and
films that are shot in one location no
um although like
so I did one called The Other Side
um back in 2014 and it had like maybe 12
locations but like we shot a good chunk
of it in this compound where you know it
was like this person they had a house
and they had a garage and they had like
an office and you know we we made like
six locations out of that one you know
and as far as like on Independent stuff
people say this all the time like you
know make it a one location shoot you
know like that that's the way to save
all your budget it's only going to save
so much because a shoot day is a shoot
day like a shoot day costs a production
what a shoot day cost of production yes
you're going to lose some time if you're
constantly company moving but you know
on an ND on average you know you're
spending I don't know five or six
thousand a day so as long as your
company moves are you know uh
structured to where you know you're on
one location for that whole day and then
maybe another location for another three
days and then one day at another
location but you're not doing like
midday company moves it it's you're not
going to save a ton of money on the
single location a little bit but not not
a ton like you might on a six day shoot
you might you might lose a half a day
and the company moves that split across
six days so like it's it's really not
that much that much of a save
and for the fifty thousand dollar budget
are you typically the editor yes yes and
the reason being I I'm not one of those
people like I have to edit everything
but you know I've been editing now for
20 years and you know at fifty thousand
dollars you know you're gonna be able to
pay an editor you know like five or six
you know maybe ten thousand tops like
and I don't feel like I'm gonna find an
editor for ten thousand dollars or five
thousand dollars that's as good as me
not to be egocentric about it but I I
it's totally a practical decision if I
you know if I had another twenty five
thousand dollars to you know pay a full
post team I would but I don't so I do it
can we break down this fifty thousand
dollar budget sure and help us
understand like where are you spending
that money okay yeah yeah
so like I'll do like a kind of a generic
like like breakdown of a fifty thousand
dollar movie so I'll talk a little bit
about craving because I'm just doing
that now so um
oh gosh it's hard without it in front of
me but um so yeah probably about on
craving 10 000
um went for a location uh right right
off the bat we needed uh like a
warehouse space uh two to three thousand
square feet and we have to build a set
so you know we're gonna spend
um I can't say exactly how much on the
rental and then 5 000 on the uh the
building of the the bar set which is the
main location and then
um there's some money in lodging because
it looks like we're gonna shoot in
Palmdale so I'm gonna have to put people
up there oh and this so this is all in
California yeah this one's going to be
in California so we're spending 10K on
the location
um we're spending it's a it's a bigger
cast than I typically work with I think
we're I think we're 10 or 12. uh like
major roles in it and so we're spending
about twelve thousand dollars on on cast
and that's not including name Talent
yeah include the three name actors and
that's closer to 20. and then
um
we're spending we're spending 5 000 on
effects materials and we've already I'm
not counting this as part of the 50 but
we had already spent almost uh 10 000 on
monster materials uh prior to the
crowdfunder
um and then but we'll just we'll just
say the the five and so that puts us to
like what 35 and then we're spending
about let's see 3 300 a day 300 a day on
catering and another 200 a day on crafty
um and then the rest of it's all in crew
and on crew on like on Indies now I you
know I start my base pay at 200 a day
nothing under I'm sorry 211 a day it's
like uh California I think like minimum
wage in 12 hours and ends up at 211 but
then key positions get a little bit more
so like the DP might make 350 or 400 or
sound might make more but for the most
part right around that 211 Mark and
we'll do this with a skeleton crew you
know it'll be it'll be a DP she'll be
she'll be running her own camera
including Focus
um there'll be a secondary camera and
when the secondary camera is not in
operation that person's also like the
the swing so their operator slash swing
and then the third person is like the
gaffer and then
um and then there's a dit that's also
our script supervisor and you know stuff
like that you know um they'll be makeup
um but it'll be one person hair and
makeup and then our effects guy who does
some makeup as well will augment some of
that and tell me again I'm sorry how
long a shoot is this so this one is
10 days I believe I'm still kind of
scheduling it out the the bar which is
the bulk of it is going to be six days
and then um the exteriors and there's a
few uh other locations like three or
four days and this food that you're
getting it's from a restaurant or these
are Caterers coming no so like in this
case I'm I'm very lucky with this and
the fact that my my niece is a
professional caterer
um she lives in Indiana and my my she's
gonna she's doing this one as a favor so
I'm basically flying her out and then
like at 300 a day she could make she
could feed a 20-person crew cast and
crew uh two meals for like 200 a day
like she's really like you know we were
the kind of poor that you know we would
spend twenty dollars and you know a
family of five would eat for a week yeah
and where is she making the food oh
she'll do it here so like like she'll
fly out on like our kitchen in Canoga
Park or um we're also if we're shooting
in Palmdale
um you know we're gonna rent Airbnb so
we might have an Airbnb that's set up
for the cooking and then you know we'll
have this stuff moved into set which is
like 10 minutes away
so post you're basically spending almost
nothing almost nothing okay so what I
like on documentaries I spend I
literally spend nothing I do it all like
I'm not an expert colorist but I can I
can do it well enough I'm real I'm
pretty darn good with sound design and
mix the only thing I can't really do
myself is like a good 5.1 but I know
several people to where I can get it
done very affordably so like on this
movie like you know I want it to be it's
a little bit higher profile than a lot
of the docs that I do so I will most
likely hire a colorist and a sound mixer
and that money has not yet been raised
so like you know like I had the
crowdfunding consultant for this and he
said you know after you shoot the movie
you know no sooner than June we'll do a
post production crowdfunder for it and
he said we could expect you know between
20 and 30 percent of what we raised
before for post so we're looking at
maybe 15 or 20 000. and not to jinx it
but let's suppose you're out there and
you need to go a day over
let's I mean there could be a hail
storms yeah okay yeah so is there money
in reserves or you know I can pull from
here my own sources yes okay so there's
not the like the way a lot of Indies
work is like you I don't have an
official contingency in the budget but I
have money from you know an outside
source that I can go to if something
like that were to happen you know or
even you know going a little bit deeper
into my own Pockets if I have to so
you're prepared to back up yeah rainy
day yeah right yeah exactly so to speak
okay that's good
can we talk about your two or three most
successful movies and then in contrast
your two or three movies that weren't a
success
we're talking like Financial correct
okay yeah I would say
um my most financially successful movie
in my career um was probably edges of
Darkness
um which I did in 2008
um it made I want to say it was it 96 it
was 96 000 in the first quarter like
when it came out this was in two eight
so like in Anchor Bay was the U.S
distributor it got a huge DVD release it
was in like like it was one of those
titles at Blockbuster where you know
like most Indie titles there'll be like
like one two or three this had like like
rows you know they're like rows six or
seven you know it was all over Hollywood
Video and it I I don't think I'll I
probably won't ever have one that does
like that good again well hopefully I
will but that one did really well you
know and um and honestly it was just and
I wasn't involved in the distribution or
marketing of it because it was all
through Anchor Bay and you know
Shoreline was our sales agent
um but I think uh it that came down to
just it was the it was the right genre
at the right time it was like before
walking dead or right at the beginning
of Walking Dead I can't remember which
but it was like like zombie stuff and
and I did the uh the sub genre combining
thing so it was like zombies it was a
zombie apocalypse but it was a story
about like vampires trying to survive in
the zombie apocalypse you know like
zombies are eating all their food so I
think that that that mishmash really
helped it you know and it was also it
was a very diverse cast you know at a
time when diverse casting wasn't
happening that much at that level you
know and um that that did that did well
um in the documentaries
um I did one
uh two years ago um called alien
contactee and you know to be frank you
know it's technically not one of my
better documentaries you know it's
mostly a single interview
um we had trouble with the sound it's
not the best shot I didn't have really
good b-roll for it but the the subject
the interviewee he was so engaging and
he had such a strong like following that
wants and needs his information that it
did really well like it was doing four
or five thousand a month you know for
almost a year and and this is something
that we made like literally for nothing
you know like shot the interview with
the guy I think I edited it in like
six or seven days like really quick and
you know and didn't have much hope for
it I was kind of like you know I'll see
what it does and it it took off
you know sorry who was the is he like an
expert yeah yeah his name's uh Louise Dr
Louise Turi um he's a he's a astrology
Guy and um he speaks he he was he was an
alien contact to he was someone that's
had you know experiences you know
meeting or you know seeing aliens you
know and he has a website where you know
people sign up and they get his
astrology stuff and he has a pretty big
following so one thing especially in the
screaming world if you have a subject or
you know an actor that's going to gain
or a influencer that's going to gain a
lot of early momentum for your movie
that momentum can carry it to a bigger
audience you know because they're
basically training the algorithm who to
show the movie to so if you have a movie
like alien contactee where this guy has
I think I think he had like maybe 10 000
regular subscribers on his website which
isn't a huge number but if you have you
know five or six thousand of them that
watch that movie in the first week and
they're all like perfectly targeted for
him so the algorithm is going to show it
the more people like them and that's how
things you know go viral and that it
basically went you know like the Amazon
equivalent of viral you know it ended
really well did and that was one that
ended up getting purged on Amazon but
then it later it got picked back up
later and started making money again
just not quite as much and it stayed
steady and it keeps getting on new
platforms it's doing well on YouTube
um really well and then um another one
in the Paranormal was the I want to
believe it was a UFO documentary we went
to a UFO convention and just like like
bum rushed the speakers like hey can we
get yoga in the corner and shoot an
interview for 50 minutes we had one guy
that agreed to do like a two hour with
us and that was a Nick Pope who he used
to be the British uh
um shoot I forget his title uh something
in defense like like his he was
basically like the British Mulder you
know and uh from X-Files right and he
would uh so he he interviewed him for
two hours so he was kind of the the you
know the main part of it and we
interviewed another six people for it
but it did all the interviews over the
course of two days
um I think I spent I spent less than a
month editing it
yeah maybe three weeks and uh and it was
a lot of stock b-roll and you know then
b-roll from the convention but but it
turned out really well and that
Community like I think was really hungry
for a documentary that wasn't like all
you know woo-woo and uh exploitive it
was just very like like brass tacks this
is what ufology is this is why we
believe in it
you know that that continues it was
never one of those that just like took
off and did you know five thousand in a
month or nothing I think the most it
ever made in the month was like maybe
1500 but it's been out for two years and
it's it's stayed there like every month
yeah and it's getting on new platforms
it just it just kicked off on a new
YouTube channel and it's doing really
well so like that continues to do great
you know and then you know narrative
wise
you know the the company I was working
for and again I like I don't have their
books I just have their word for it but
you know like the talking dog Movie that
that probably that probably outdid the
edges of Darkness maybe five or six
hundred thousand
and then the ones that didn't do so well
what do you think was the difference
so
like rise of the undead my first one and
trap that was my third movie both of
those like I I really made them in the
dark like not thinking about audience or
any of that I'm just this is the movie
I'm gonna make I don't know who's gonna
watch it or where I'm just gonna make it
and and try to find distribution and and
I did but neither of those movies did
very well
you know like uh you know rise of the
undead you know in the first iteration
of that we never I didn't and I didn't
see anything off of it you know the it
was a we did the deal with the orc
entertainment who was pretty notoriously
not great back then that they're not in
business anymore and uh then trap I'm
trying to remember who distributed trap
I don't even remember I don't remember
rooster but we I didn't make much money
from this that one actually was only
with a distributor for about a year and
then I talked them into releasing me
from the contract and did
self-distribution with it made a little
bit and that and trap was so low budget
that I think it actually did eventually
make its budget back it was like I think
we made it for five
but um not well not that well but the
bigger one that really and the one that
pretty much made me almost quit
filmmaking was uh the campus or uh it's
called death day now ITN changed the
title so that just that one kills me
um so we we shot it in 2018 and you know
I I'd done all the other movies and I
was basically trying to follow the
business plan that like AMG the company
I worked for had laid out you know do a
movie for around 50 000 you have these
elements you know keep it low and you
know it was a single location horror
movie it had a mix of zombies ghosts and
uh
uh uh what do you call it a uh
um
like stalker slasher movie you know it
was it was a woman that was dying over
and over and every time she died she
would come back in a different like
horror movie scenario you know a little
death day but which is why they happy
death day which is why the distributor
actually changed the title to death day
to write off those coattails but anyway
we we finished it off and what had
happened was this was right so we
greenlit the movie like right as I was
like Amazon was about at its peak you
know and has this movie was greenlits
when Amazon did their first like take it
from whatever 15 cents an hour to five
cents an hour like took it down and the
market DVD like it was already shrinking
but it shrank really crazy between like
2017 and 2018 like the market just
wasn't there anymore not not like it was
so the movie came out and I was I was
projecting it at like you know like a
minimum it was going to make like you
know 3 000 a month but I was expecting
more like you know 20 000 a month came
out it made like twelve hundred dollars
a month one it made uh like a thousand
dollars a month to 700 month three it
was down to four on month four and then
I was like ah and the other big problem
was I initially I did not go with
distribution I was like I'm gonna
self-distribute this I'm gonna do the
Amazon thing and then I'll let thumb Hub
do the other things so I and I just done
the Amazon and it just wasn't going I
was like God we're never gonna make even
close to the budget back and I had all
of these investors and you know people
like talking about hey we need our money
back so I got a little bit like
desperate and like I need to find a
distributor for it and at that point
we'd already released it so a lot of
Distributors won't touch it so I found a
sales agent that could make a deal with
ITN and ITN would take it so I did and
the sales agent deal I just I didn't do
my due diligence it wasn't a great deal
and we like I think the movie made
around 30 Grand in the first year and we
never saw any of it so I ended up uh
threatening legal action against the
sales agent I got out of that deal and
now my deals directly with ITN so I get
the money directly from them but that 30
was already gone and it had already done
its two years so it's like now it makes
you know about a
thousand dollars or less a quarter
you know and and that money you'll just
I that I'll never be able to pay those
people back unless I do it out of pocket
which I've kind of started to do
but yeah and it was just you know I
didn't I I my eye wasn't on the ball you
know I was I was distracted by some
other things and other business stuff
and it just it didn't work out
do you think you'll ever use a sales
agent again I would never use a sales
agent again never you know and and I'm
not saying that they're not good ones or
whatnot but I just think that the market
has changed the only reason I even went
to that one in the first place was
because I made a huge mistake off the
bat like if you're
if you're going to distribute a thumb if
you're going to self-distribute and use
that's what you're going to do stick
with it go all in self-distribute if
you're going to do a distributor stick
with them you know like stop you know
don't try to don't try to pull it Midway
you know unless something's drastically
wrong like like honestly if I just would
have stayed the course with
self-distribution because I'm sorry I
said I was going to do film Hub but that
that's actually not 100 true because
film Hub I wasn't really aware of it at
that time like I I was just becoming
aware of it so like if if I just would
have held on to that for a year and then
done film Hub and the other platforms
and then it would have hit 2B and I
don't know that I would have saw the
whole budget back but I would have saw a
lot more than I did but you know I made
the mistake of you know getting
desperate and going for the sales agent
and the distributor and I'm not 100 on
the distributor either but I just you
know I I did it out of the desperation
and it was a bad move
with the alien documentary where you
went to the convention you said it was
pulled off Amazon but then put back on
was that because watch time was low or
you know it's really hard to say
um so you know Amazon has a thing they
call a customer engagement ranking and
you know it's what they base how much
they pay you now and if your ranking is
so under a certain amount there is a
good chance you'll get purged but the
other thing that could happen with the
purging is you know because people gotta
remember there aren't human beings like
like
watching all these movies you know there
are algorithms there are third parties
that come in and they they they're just
scanning stuff you know like they're
looking for certain you know key phrases
or images that will spark something and
that's how red flags get sent up so on
the initial pass something might get
through that they don't like you know
but maybe it'll get discovered you know
or what they say is they're always
looking at you know audience data so if
you have a movie up and you know 100
people click on it to watch it and they
click off within 15 or 20 seconds
chances are that's gonna get that's
going to get yanked you know so I I
found on the few that I had purged that
it was it had a lot it had more to do
with audience retention is what I would
say but I've heard other anecdotes about
you know stuff got pulled because it was
too you know the nudity was too extreme
or the violence or you know it was
political I've heard stuff like that too
but for me it was always watch time and
and to figure out your retention on
Amazon it's it's actually kind of easy
because they and their metrics they have
like your total amount of hours watched
and then they'll have your total viewers
and if you just take the you know total
time divided by the total viewers I'll
give you an average of how long they're
watching it you won't get the specific
metrics but you can get a ballpark and
if you have a if you have a 90 minute
movie and you know your your average
watch time is around 10 minutes that's
probably not great
we posted a poll on our YouTube channel
Community page with the question do you
trust film Distributors the poll
received over 8 000 votes 85 percent of
those polls said they do not trust film
Distributors how do you feel about the
negative reputation surrounding
Distributors so I'm going to be a little
contrarian on this one
um
I think there are bad predatory
Distributors out there and I think there
was a time when there was a lot more of
them but
so I'm not saying that bad Distributors
don't exist they're not out there or
there's not even a lot of them maybe
there's a lot of them but I I think that
80 I would say 80 of the negative
chatter around filmmakers and
Distributors stems from filmmakers
misunderstanding of how distribution
actually works and what the market will
bear for their movie like I've seen
filmmaker after filmmaker saying this
distributor ripped me off they're lying
to me I know my movie made more than
this and
nine times out of ten it didn't you know
like it didn't like they're like a movie
your movie's not entitled
to make money in the market you know
like some of them don't you can have you
know like death day for example like
it's it's not the best movie in the
world but it is it's competent it has
all of the like sellable elements it's
all in Focus you know it's it you know
it's it it should have done better but
it didn't and it wasn't like the
distributor hiding numbers from me or
anything is like it just didn't do well
and I think a lot of times it's easier
for us to point the finger and say it's
their fault or they're lying or they
cheated then the movie just didn't do
well you know and I think that's what
happens a lot of the time and then the
other thing is you know it's just in
contracts and you know a distributor is
a business they're looking to make money
so the first contract they give you it's
going to be boilerplate or it's going to
be you know skewed to favor them you
know I have never I haven't worked with
one distributor well maybe one that
wouldn't negotiate a contract so like if
you don't do your due diligence and
don't realize that hey I made a fifty
thousand dollar movie and a thirty
thousand dollar sales cap is crazy if if
you don't know that and you sign a
thirty thousand dollar sales cap
it's kind of like you know I'm not
saying it's all your fault but you
didn't you signed a bad deal you know
like you had the contract you know you
should know that thirty thousand on
fifty is a like that's a bad deal it's a
red flag you know or you know these
companies that are running around now
trying to suck trying to like have
filmmakers sign 25-year contracts like
that's that's ridiculous in this day and
age you know so like you should if and
if you don't know that you need to
educate yourself so like if you're gonna
go out and look for a distributor and
you know know the points on the contract
educate yourself you know like there are
and the thing that makes me mad is like
today there's no shortage of information
out there about these Distributors you
know and the ones that are bad that are
really predatory like you can you can
find it pretty quick I mean you can
Google predatory distributor and and
these names will pop up you know like
avoid them it's so I I you know there
are situations like distributor where
like that was like straight up that no
fault of the filmmakers like that
happened that was a horrible like bad
situation you know and there are
Distributors out there that are doing
like really shady crap and you know
again and no fault of the filmmaker but
I would say more often than not a lot of
the negative things around them is is
it's just it's just not understanding
distribution
and these boilerplate contracts how many
pages are they I mean it could be
anywhere from you know I've seen some
that are single pages but I've seen
others that are you know 10 or 12 Pages
they are and then they're long you know
and like and I don't understand all the
ins and outs of contracts but you know I
go to other producers that are more
experienced if I'm dealing with a new
distributor and I'll give it to them or
you know and I know a lot of people like
well I can't afford a lawyer but you
know you can you can get a lawyer to
look at an entertainment attorney to
look at a contract for a few hundred
dollars you know and I and I know that
sounds you know whatever maybe that's uh
you know like an entitled like hey a few
hundred dollars it's nothing but if
you're looking at making money on your
movie you have to you have to take some
of these safeguards so if you don't know
the distributor and don't have a
relationship with them or don't know
anybody that does get out there and find
somebody that does like it's really easy
to track down other producers now you
can go on 9db Pro look up a distributor
click on 10 or 12 of the movies that
they've distributed and start contacting
producers you know and you know some of
them won't want to talk to you some of
them will you but you talk to
enough you can get a lay of the land and
then have a lawyer look at the contract
or somebody that you trust that has more
experience than you and go from there
and when you did take a contractor
contracts to an attorney were there
certain things that were eye-opening to
you where you kind of thought oh yeah
this sounds fine it's legalese for
something but I'm sure it's fine and
then they pointed out oh this is
actually a red flag
um not not really I I mean for me I I've
I've been fairly lucky with with two
exceptions uh with Distributors
um and most of the things that I got
back was just like kind of just what I
mentioned before like uh one of them was
like this is too long a license term
like they wanted 10 years and they're
like you know you should get this down
to no more than seven probably five you
know or they would say that their sales
cap on this is twenty five thousand
dollars uh your movie was budgeted at
42. that's half of your budget like
that's probably more than what and and
honestly if you're talking about lower
end Distributors and anybody that's
trying to charge any more than fifteen
thousand to me that's a red flag
red flag like because I I you see it
over and over they there's no way
they're putting in you know uh thirty
thousand dollars into promotion of those
movies you know they make a one sheet
maybe a trailer you know every now and
then some of these Distributors will
really get behind like a single movie
and they might spend that but I think
most of the time they do not so I just
don't I
unless my movie was starting to get over
the hundred thousand dollar range I
wouldn't even consider a distributor
with a with a sales cap over 15. why do
we often hear that filmmakers are not
making money with their Distributors
however we often hear the other side
from people who work in the business
that you can make great money in
distribution
so
I think some of it is you know
aggressive greener on the other side
stuff I think some of it is just like
not true like I I've talked to you know
like I've talked to several you know
Distribution Company owners over the
past you know three or four years like
doing my channel and whatnot
and you know they have they have to
present a sunny
front like things are good you know the
movies are making money but you know
when you actually get into the nitty
gritty and look at the numbers the
overall generally the like they're not
so you know I so I I think some of it is
from that and I think and I think also
you know usually there's so many
different levels of movies and I think
some of the some of the filmmakers
aren't necessarily like at the same
level that some of the Distributors are
that are that are making more money so
like say you hear uh I'm just going to
name a distributor off the top of my
head somebody like uh like gravitas
Ventures is saying like we had a great
year with you know and and maybe they
did but you know they they're
representing you know over 2 000 titles
so maybe they had luck with a certain
type of movie and maybe your movie is
not that type of movie you know what I'm
saying so I I think I think it is such
an individualized thing film
distribution and it's so based on an
individualized film like you know I've
just sat here and talked for three hours
about generalities right but it's all
specific to the film into the filmmaker
so you know like a company could be
doing great overall but your individual
film might totally flop with them and
then and the other thing with that you
know people you hear this all the time
filmmakers talk about uh you know
Distributors like oh if I was with this
distributor instead of that one the
movie would have done so much better
it it wouldn't you know they're all
going to the same places they're all
getting to the same platforms they're
all doing the same basic amount of
marketing or no marketing you know it's
like it's all the same you know like
people ask me all the time like you know
what are you because I do Indie rights
and film Hub a lot which do you prefer
which is better
I mean I've had I've had movies make
more with one movies make more with the
other it just it it just depends on the
movie you know and that movie
you know there's no way to tell for sure
but I'd make a thousand dollar bet that
I want to believe would have made just
about the same amount of money with film
Hub as it did with Indie rights or you
know something that did really well with
film Hub like alien contact team my dad
might have done the exact same thing
with it you probably would have done the
exact same thing with Indy rates in
general
the movie is going to make the same it's
going to get in the same places there's
some Distributors that have you know
like a few better connections you know
maybe with this platform or that
platform maybe they'll get a slightly
better deal or maybe this maybe this
company has a good relationship with
shutter and you're doing horror movies
and maybe they maybe they're good to go
for for that but generally speaking
they're all getting to the same place
they're all making the same amount of
money so it comes down to who do you
trust who is transparent who is going to
pay you and who's going to pay you on
time and who's not gonna you know
screw you over and you know in my
experience you know Distributors like
Indie rights or distribution platforms
like film Hub they are trustworthy
they're straight up they're transparent
you know to me it's a no-brainer you
know like I there are Distributors out
there that people would say like well
you know maybe maybe your film will do
better if you went to like Vision films
and and
maybe it would but I but I would say
that the amount that I'm paying on sales
fees and the extra stuff that they
charge to do those extra things might
not be worth the more money you're
making
would you say if someone can't afford an
attorney that may be distribution
is not for them because they could end
up hurting themselves severely
that's that's that's that's that's a
good that's a good point
um I I would yeah I that's something to
consider but but again I you know I I've
signed I've signed a few contracts
without ever going to an attorney but
like just talking to other producers or
you know doing the IMDb thing and
contacting other producers and at the
end of the day
you know everything's a risk like it's
it's all a risk self-distribution is a
risk distribution is a risk you know
doing it yourself going it with them
like there's never a you know a sure
thing and there's never a
you just you never know at a certain
point like filmmaking it's it's a trust
fall you know at a certain point you
either jump in or or get out you know so
you know like I like I wouldn't go to a
new distributor with craving you know
like I wouldn't do it you know like
there's too much on the line for it and
yeah sure maybe I would have you know a
better chance to get to like Netflix or
Hulu or something if I went with a
bigger distributor but distributor that
maybe I haven't worked with to me it's
just like it's not worth it
you know and I know that's easy for me
to say having worked with different
distributors and having choices but you
know I'm I'm telling you if people if
you if you trust what I'm saying like
like Indie rights out there there they
are trustworthy they'll get you on
platforms you'll get paid you know and
they're they're one they're good you
know and there are others but like
they're they're the ones I would say
that because I've had the most
experience with